[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number five
what is a creationist I suppose that in
the most general sense of the word
creationist you know a creationist is
anyone that believes in some sort of a
creator a creator of the universe or at
least a creator of life within the
universe so that would be pretty much
all Christians Muslims Jews Hindus even
groups of people today that believe that
aliens somehow engineered humans or
seeded life on planet Earth I guess they
would also be termed creationists as
well and by the way there's a growing
group of people that believe that
without any evidence so that's the
definition of a creationist I guess if
you want to be really broad about it it
would include all those potential people
but typically today when someone says
that they are a creationist what they
mean is that they reject aspects of the
science of evolution usually major
aspects of the science of evolution for
religious purposes they feel like the
discoveries that are being made in
biology do not jive with their
interpretation of Scripture or with
their spiritual beliefs in one way or
another so that is a creationist today
that's what we typically mean when we
talk about creationists people that
reject aspects of the science of
evolution for religious purposes now not
all Christians are creationists by that
definition I mean of course all
Christians believe in a creator but
there's a huge and growing proportion of
Christians that actually have no problem
with the science of evolution they
accept it just fine they study it even
they do research in it they teach it
it's not a problem for them probably
most notably is the Catholic Church the
the Pope has come out saying that you
know evolution is OK
there's this growing number of religious
folks that are finding the science of
evolution to be ok so that's good it's
great now within the world of
creationism the creationist movement
there is actually lots of different
branches there's been a lot of different
you know divisions within the movement
creationism mainly got its start within
Christianity and if you take a look at
Christianity you'll see that there are
lots of different types of Christianity
and actually there are lots of different
types of creationism as well there's
really three like big groups and they
think fairly differently about things
there are young earth creationists these
are people that believe that the earth
is literally only somewhere between six
to ten thousand years old and that the
earth was created in six days there are
a lot of evangelical Christians that
accept this type of creationism the
young earth creationist movement is also
growing within Islam right now again
there are lots of Muslims that are not
creationists I mean of course they all
believe in a creator but they don't have
a an issue with the theory of evolution
the second group would be old earth
creationists and these people believe
that the earth is actually old they
accept the discoveries that we've been
making in geology the earth is indeed
millions of years old and then last but
not least we have the intelligent design
movement and the intelligent design
movement is really interesting because
it actually started off not really as
its own unique movement but as a way to
hide creationism so what happened is
that here in the United States we have
what's called a separation between
church and state and state-funded
schools the state funded education
system is not supposed to indoctrinate
children with any type of religious
ideas so we're not supposed to push
Christianity on our students in a public
school for example and because of that
when people were trying to teach
creationism which is clearly a religious
doctrine they were getting in trouble at
school these teachers were and so the
creationists got together and they came
up with kind of a rebranding for
creationism occulta intelligent design
and they kind of distanced Christianity
from it they tried to at least so if you
look at all of the intelligent design
literature you won't see any mention of
six days of creation you won't see any
mention of the God of the Old Testament
they talk about an intelligent designer
and they're very vague as to what
designer is and exactly how that
designer goes about you know tinkering
and designing living things you know
they even suggest that my designer might
be an alien and so on and the
intelligent design movement has since
kind of taken on a life of its own and
sometimes the intelligent design people
end up butting heads with the
creationists the young earth
creationists it's really interesting
that we had this you know this this
emergence of a new type of creationism
that really just got its start because
of a legal issue fascinating but so
that's that's kind of just a basic
overview of what creationism is I'm
going to do some videos specifically on
young earth creationism
and they'll be some video specifically
on intelligent design there's a bunch of
really interesting concepts and
intelligent design there's like
irreducible complexity and specified
complexity and so on
and here in a couple of weeks I am
actually going to be going to Cincinnati
I'm going to visit the young earth
creationist Museum and I'm going to
learn the details of what young earth
creationists believe I mean it already
read a lot of stuff and the coolest
thing about this is that I'm going to
meet dr. Nathaniel Jensen he is a
trained a Harvard trained biologist who
is a young earth creationist so they I
mean that's like ridiculously rare I
think he might be the only one actually
he is he got his undergrad in genetics
or bioinformatics and his PhD in
developmental biology I believe so he's
a really interesting character and I'm
gonna hang out with them and learn what
he believes and actually reading his
book right now that he put out called
replacing Darwin which you know he's got
lofty goals and he and I are in
discussions right now about doing a
public debate and I think it will be
really really neat to do that because
he's again he's like he's I would say
he's one of the smartest dudes in the
creationist movement and to be able to
you know go kind of head-to-head with
him would be would be a lot of fun that
debate will be filmed and put on the
Internet if it happens his he actually
wants to
do it but the Answers in Genesis which
is the company that he works for they're
they're kind of reluctant for some
reason or they seem to be my
conversation with him two weeks from now
I'm not gonna film because I just don't
want him to be I don't want the
conversation to be like on camera and
weird I want to just hang out with him
chat with them he seems like a really
cool guy really nice guy I just want to
get to know him and what he believes and
let him get to know who I am and you
know kind of my my history so look
forward to that debate in the future
when I get back from my trip we'll have
a lot more to talk about as far as
creationism goes to summarize what we
learned here today a creationist is a
person that rejects the science of
evolution or at least you know major
aspects of the science of evolution for
religious purposes next question